I keep getting eye inflammation, both eyes, and it comes and goes, but getting more painful
each time, any suggestions.
Oh wow.
Huh.
Well, if you investigated the source, is there something that you're, that you're
topically being exposed to, that could be causing eye inflammation, but I don't know,
that's really not by specialty, as eye inflammation, but you want to look, you got to think through
this and think through possible causes, is there some, you know, dust that you're exposed
to that you could have, you know, an allergic reaction to, I don't remember your last blood
work, if yes, sydophils, who are elevated, suggesting possible, a topical type allergen,
I'd, you know, anything else that you're putting on topically, that could cause eye inflammation
and collagen, especially both eyes, you think it's something you're being exposed to, I've
not heard of like food-based things causing eye inflammation, but that's a tough one.
I would, I'd go in and do an eye doctor and see if they can investigate something going
on, I don't, I don't know, I don't know, I apologize.